[Aplausos]
el movimiento en defensa el derecho al
aborto se toma las calles al menos en 70
ciudades miles de personas rechazan la
derogación de robert su wei luego que el
tribunal supremo anulara el fallo que
daba el derecho constitucional al aborto
en eeuu
hoy para mí es trágico porque luchamos
mucho para que se aprobara esta ley en
1973 cuando finalmente se consiguió la
victoria ahora 50 años después nos la
han quitado esto está mal está
totalmente mal las mujeres morían por
abortar en aquel entonces estábamos
tratando de proteger los derechos de las
mujeres la vida de las mujeres y ahora
nos han quitado todo starway formas
las senadoras demócratas ellis edward y
tim smith pidieron el presidente yo va a
ir en declarar una emergencia de salud
pública para proteger el acceso al
aborto la casa blanca prevé desafíos
legales a las restricciones de las
mujeres que tendrán que movilizarse a
otras ciudades para aportar
en las multitudinarias protestas que
empezaron el viernes ya se reportan
choques con la policía e incidentes con
grupos antiaborto que salieron a
celebrar la decisión
es un momento muy emocionante para todos
nosotros teníamos 80 personas pro-vida
en una habitación juntas cuando nos
enteramos que la decisión de anular roe
versus wave se había producido y todos
estábamos emocionados y entusiasmados
sabemos que todavía hay que seguir
trabajando y que queda mucho por hacer
el fallo afectaría a 36 millones de
mujeres tras la decisión al menos 6
estados ya prohibieron el aborto y otros
26 se preparan para la prohibición en
esa nación solamente 16 estados están a
favor del aborto durante este fin de
semana el país escuchará el rechazo
masivo a una decisión que afectará la
vida de millones de mujeres según varios
organismos de salud incluso más allá de
las fronteras de eeuu